I'm back what did I miss mark I'm
constructing a Wade soundboard at the
moment yeah yeah I'm ready I'm ready
Worstell oh you're not ready you're not
oh you already Hey I'm sorry what was
that wait I thought you were just
punching babies I thought that was your
[ __ ] okay you're smart people couldn't
even see the game on that one lick see
and what you're gonna have to do you're
gonna you're gonna go snatch the vaad
from their stream put my FaceCam
over their face cam and that's what
we're gonna deal with okay cool
[Music]
mark I'm constructing a Wade soundboard
at the moment that's you baby
all right I'm ready Oh Globox whoo I
like lo box all right yeah good good
good impression to me yeah thanks I'm
sorry we'll look that way I don't have
that power but I could have that power
sorry
got him no you didn't get me I've got
you
no okay nevermind Bob you're gonna put
my editor out of a job this is so good I
just can pick this up raw everybody
needs some of this I listen I don't oh
you're not gonna you're not gonna pull
the wool over my eyes twice I've got you
[Laughter]
shut up Brett that's my bit okay I'm
sorry I thought you were just punching
baby I'm just gonna get this out of the
way cuz I know it's gonna happen so wait
I want
[Music]
Wow one game without screaming at each
other
cursing each other out episode that
everyone hated that we that is one of my
favorite things we ever did and nobody
liked it you even drunk why didn't you
play a card wait
I was busy yelling at my jack wait a
minute I was screaming at them so I
could come back and be nice and calm to
you well that's unfortunate not making
this mistake again
oh nice well played well that what juice
bag it's Globox
I like lo box it's kind of a big liar
yeah do you like these do you like this
hand that I have chat isn't it amazing
[Music]
hey listen buddy okay
this don't [ __ ] sweet baby agree okay
that's not it uh why not
okay that's fine I won't have this hand
for very long why wait what huh wait why
what's happening what do you know that I
don't know well I know what's in my head
apparently everybody has everything holy
[ __ ]
we're gonna yell I thought it was gonna
be chilly no no no one's yelling we're
calm I'm chill
let me chill ma'am you know I'm sure we
could turn up the volume a bit
that's a nice little pun that I hate Oh
turn it I laughed at it because I got it
I didn't get it I my brain like I've
always realized that you're smart and
not a complete idiot like you know like
a Globox is you I didn't think it was
but now I have a sneaking suspicion that
no I have been told no it never never
never was not even the one time right
well right unnecessary right why why I
had to try jump why why okay Bob you're
gonna laugh I don't know if I'm gonna
laugh but I had to do that but but I'm
not laughing no no I don't think I'm
gonna [ __ ] laugh what I was right
wait you know what what here you know
you're gonna laugh you are you're gonna
you're gonna eat this because it's me I
mean all right okay well it didn't do
any difference I guess so I only heard
you once no well this is an interesting
turn of events that I'm not to Bob gonna
laugh is Bob gonna laugh I think they're
gonna laugh Bob you're probably - laughs
laughs be like laughs god [ __ ] damn
it I feel like it's unlikely that I'm
going to laugh Bob will kill you want
anything but blue blue so glad you said
that here I know I would have preferred
more jokes in my pants would have
preferred not blue yes he didn't he well
you know what you're right I just
thought as Fred
we could've collectively you know work
together something you're gonna laugh
because I've got two of these you know
what you're right that was creepy you
snagged it okay well you guys are gonna
laugh yeah oh [ __ ] that's the wrong one
all right whatever
Oh purple dragon why do this we're all
laughing yeah you know what all right
there we go that's a good one maybe why
can't I jump in on this you know what
you're right yeah have you never edited
your own video it's been a long time I
don't believe this
all right I believe this I thought I
wanted to play this card but I guess I
don't want to play this card please do
mind we're gonna laugh because you're
gonna laugh
oh yeah Bob why pretty funny right mark
isn't that funny aren't you laughing
it's so funny right I get it I get why
you're always so happy all the time I
get it yeah see that that head is jovial
is what that happy yeah and it's actual
delight in the form of cards yeah wait
you're gonna laugh maybe god laughs
you're gonna laugh I'm kind of glad that
I didn't I laughs you know what [ __ ] all
of this okay Oh Mike that's I'm gonna
laugh you're gonna just relax
oh the joke's on me for the last that's
not what you want to see Bob am I gonna
laugh no probably not
okay I don't have any good jokes okay I
got Joe quiet wait go go to the market
wait I just want to see what you got
I just want to see what you're working
for groceries groceries no to get away
from his horrible looking hey whoa we're
being chill everything laughing my bro
it was chill man I was chill chocolate
out you know when life gives you some
Stinky's you just got to keep it in
perspective and chuckle them right out
of your system yeah well [ __ ] back you
plebeian piece of ass me thank you
that's that's pretty unkillable quit
changing the goddamn color why I feel
like everyone including Globox is being
pretty chill you know I'm very chill
despite the fact that there is a spiked
dildo going into my [ __ ] right now
really well that's probably against
terms well see you kind of did that to
yourself what's funny you're gonna laugh
you're gonna laugh oh wow yeah that's
that's exactly what I was hoping for
yeah man don't mind me laughing behind
my smoke here really fun your your
concealed laughter is even more joyous
than your actor is the best form of
Education yep that's the one medication
I like okay goddamn turn so that's fine
that's okay mark yeah yeah uh-huh
[Music]
you're gonna laugh you're gonna laugh
you're Globox funny that's so funny
no I think it's I think it's probably
Marx that's gonna have to have a laugh
wait hey Globox listen oh no hey well if
they're both dreams so Reds not gonna
help you well that's unfortunate how do
I not okay well that seems so unlikely
you know it's just funny right sometimes
funny Globox you are gonna laugh with
buddy
so many goups on them you know we vomit
in your own mouth and you try to swallow
it that's basically what this hand is
like but to my eyes but Globox didn't
play there sevens all right cool but I'm
gonna draw some more cards
is it an impressive hand you know like
you you're gonna laugh when you
impressive who impressive I'm gonna take
it right now for myself
oh they drew okay green it is Green is
not a good green green is not a good I
can just tell you that greens okay
that's what woah box is gonna be
laughing if it's green so just be chill
look mark yeah clicked it okay never
mind nothing's gonna happen
just take that whole I can't believe you
didn't challenge wait all that wait how
many things can you possibly fit inside
your [ __ ] new place for thing I can
fit three sperm whales and one half of
Grandma one half of Grandma you too
grandma
well wait you're gonna laugh my dude
look at that oh this is
yes I I think you've got some joy to
spread some things to spread some of
them might be joyous mark do wait you're
gonna laugh you're gonna laugh in my
card you're really gonna laugh what card
what color do we want guys what cause
gonna get you to the win as green as the
hand that's the all right its lowest
okay really just gonna hand that to me
uh-huh all right everyone's everyone's
gonna laugh Oh what was that weird okay
Mark's gonna enjoy this I have so many
choices all right I did it
oh no no that's cool that's cool no you
see the way you smack that six out there
yeah well I'll be right back you're
gonna laugh gonna get funny what are you
gonna get I don't understand
I don't either oh my god Wade's gonna
laugh oh cool Wow it's going to chuckle
it up cool oh that's the end wait does
that happen you to draw and don't do
anything yeah when you when you timeout
you don't get to play but no don't why
would you do that to him oh that's we're
gonna he was gonna laugh Globox when you
do that to me laughs oh dear Oh No okay
well mark okay
I'm wearing my cloak sweater oh wow a
glow box you're gonna laugh but [ __ ] you
whoa I'm at fudge
you know why
that's fine hey come on man I just I
didn't do anything to you no it's not at
you and mad at the universe well that'll
solve all of our problems those nine
cards you earned it man you got the
extra cards okay no age all right helm
sure that's okay all right we did a
whole lot there oh cool
um deep calm deep breaths from flying up
and down the seven flights of stairs in
my mansion estate wait man you can't
afford it Turner you're gonna laugh for
dinner but I do live in a ten the
billion dollar house in Cincinnati's
prime place of residence and he lands it
way to bring it home with just trying to
keep it believable you know everybody
knows about Cincinnati's prime land real
estate yeah everybody does what is it
rhubarb is that like a turnip what's a
rubber is a rhubarb I think that's what
you use for safe sex
rubber baby rubber you got to make sure
you have a rubber bright mm-hmm yeah
that's it it's actually harvested from a
rare when it cuts you off and it just
sounds like you say rubber it's less
funny and it's gross
oh dear hey mark only has one card left
yeah the most dangerous game box I swear
to god oh no it's okay you're gonna
laugh let me laugh
Wow what color you want there Bob uh
anything but yellow I guess I don't know
just to make you just to make you feel
better
I don't want anyone to feel like they're
excluded you know you're right thank you
all have a lot of cards I feel like we
need to gang up on Globox that's what I
feel like that doesn't help anybody win
though no but we could just gang up on
Globox and it's it'll be it'll be funny
you know everyone will laugh okay all
right
yeah we're you're gonna laugh wait your
box won't feel better yeah you know
actually I kind of do those nice
fortunate that it ended on yellow but
thank you kind sir
thank you well I I'm gonna laughs listen
yeah come on then that's rough
a little bit celery bait is not the word
you want to use there celery bait sounds
like people made puns I tried to make a
lettuce celebrate it was lettuce celery
bait and celery bait just it doesn't you
know it rubs me the wrong way
weed you know you must have been paying
it you know oh you know hey listen just
because he did it to you doesn't mean he
did it on purpose okay usually I just
happen to have a lot of well I have did
you have a lot it was blue once upon a
time you're gonna laugh oh I am gonna
laugh mark how did you even do this all
right look look man did you make this
happen
look I don't know what
did not you want to see how funny was
let me take a look
Pass okay never mind deal with that
problem okay I guess I'll look at my oh
hey my old handbag you're gonna laugh
you're gonna laugh you're gonna laugh
Bob you're really gonna laugh with this
one you me no not laughing not me
laughing I am laughing as they say not
me laughing I was laughing impossible I
just I could jump in and we'll never
know how many cards well box gets up
juice what if you get blue again for
like a second
you go back to yellow after that are all
right well come on Globox
hey Marco me main man your green is not
one of the colors you know what wait I
will save you from this fate oh my hand
doesn't even load correctly it's all
stack take it I guess no I mean like I
can't see oh nice oh whoa the game is
breaking oh whoa okay guys I'll be here
just leave it right I've got a plan okay
yeah really dig through my deck for that
one my plan sorry I wanna I got it come
on not like this
well that's not what you want to see
well this is awkward
Oh No but why would you do that for him
well mark I'm just curious to see how
many things you have in your hand all
right you're gonna laugh but I don't
wait wait wait wait no you have to have
I didn't have but gosh darnit oh well
who's laughing now that's the question
listen so I'm just glad I got to do this
I'm really curious yeah you you you want
to see this it's nonsense
oh okay this it's the colors it
consolidates in two colors I got it I
got
I changed my mind okay fair enough
hey wait take a look at that fair's fair
right wait um
fair is fair if you're not gonna answer
I can answer for you
fair's fair well lo box let me tell you
something about hey you got the head
back first fair I did I did get the
handbag actually I'm glad that's all
fair here fair's fair we're fair friends
and we're fair fair to each other fair
is fair wait a minute
hey Bob do you mind this I mean you
don't really give me a chance to answer
thanks for asking though Oh for [ __ ]
sake I grabbed my mouse at the wrong
angle you're gonna laugh wait oh dude so
funny gonna laugh tell you what dude so
mm-hmm find the chuckles I just want to
keep I just want to be on on-brand
oh here mark I got you homie know what
don't thank God
oh no I forgot how those worked laughs
but I say it myself there I've got I've
got some jokes don't you worry about it
okay tell them I bet I'll laugh well if
you're not gonna let me tell them how am
I supposed to tell them a visual joke do
you have to have it's like a physical
gag you know huh
it's more of a that's a good one ha ha
ha joke I get it yeah see you got it yes
[ __ ]
mmm-hmm as [ __ ] here wait wait does what
what's going on he knows what's good
okay I'm not I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding I didn't mean that I didn't mean
that
how long is this one round been half Oh
got him I'll mark out him whatever
whatever it's all good it's all the same
it's all good it's all good
oh not green no not green you're not
green perfect listen wait mark Greene's
pretty good what you want green sorry I
got a can't this isn't even fun have to
die but I mean like if you think about
it you might laugh no no not green no
wait no hang on green no no no I don't
want to laugh I can't laughs I've been
capable that's the cool eight you played
there and that's thank you going well
you know yeah no no no you know what
Globox you need to calm down a little
bit okay bow whoa hey you're number one
in my book no wait two fingers to say
well okay you've been demoted to fourth
in my book several hundred more one's
not gonna jump in there Globox ah got
him Bob you're gonna laugh I don't want
to laugh I'm [ __ ] well Bob that
wasn't fair you need it you need to play
Wade oh you're going to laugh
well hey man Wow oh wow what well that
escalated in a weird direction that I
did not anticipate
I jumped in also it was my turbo Oh sick
sick play play all right you guys are
gonna laugh okay yeah you were right
that we were gonna laugh oh you guys you
guys are gonna laugh whenever you
eventually all see what happened to this
hand that was once in who know Han
everything's fine everything's fine
laughs deep deep deep deep deep breaths
okay well hey Mark what color it was
I don't read maybe I know I'm not done
eating please damn it all right not Reds
at all you lied to me you lied stall
Wade made a strong counter-argument what
can I do
oh well you want it you want it you want
yeah you want this let's light this
candle huh that's light oh look I don't
look how that you know when this when
this game doesn't end in in 13 hours
we're all gonna laugh everyone's go
I got a draw huh man drawing has
certainly been my strong suit this game
haha oh that's a good play that's good
play I got you're gonna laugh done are
you done
punching Wade well answer that's the
strong no mark I feel like I didn't get
to experience your joke the way you
would want to know okay I didn't even
get a chance to get told a joke I just
got the punch punch lines that straight
to the punch whatever don't don't look
at those that's not good I'm looking
well I appreciate you leaving a 5 on
there so I'm here for you hey too late
you're gonna laugh
yeah you always get it like haven't have
a millimeter before I do well I'm sorry
I'm sorry I just had blood burn to my
place I got your back
Bob that's what we call a winning hand
over there so just oh it's truly it
truly do be like that yeah oh wait no
it's okay wait hang on I can make this I
can make this good for you Bob I could
make it good for you you're gonna laugh
if I do this then I can make it good for
you right yeah I was pretty good
I made it good for you Oh God pile this
up oh no don't do that ten cards hold
man that's funny oh you're gonna laugh
you're gonna laugh wow really but oh wow
well that happens after their disappear
okay just please get us out of here I
can't take as much humor can we take a
government-mandated break you gonna stop
laughing
[Music]
you